hi it's Marcus here and we're really
privileged to be here with Samuel Leeds
in his beautiful home here it is eight
I'm telling you it is a stonker of a
mansion in a really lovely part of
London and we've known each other for
several years but I've never actually
actually I haven't interviewed anybody
so you're my first darling so basically
what we're doing is we are asking a an
extremely successful entrepreneur
property investor father husband exactly
how he became so successful how does he
think in order to help you become even
more successful even faster than you are
now so I'm really looking forward to
this interview so Samuel thank you so
much for your time thank you for having
me
all right so something of great to see
you in your new house it's absolutely
fantastic I have to say thanks so much I
mean it's a mansion is the first time
you've been here first time oh man yeah
too too too much too much time has
passed and lots of each other I know no
that's very very true but when when did
we meet
okay the first time I saw you was when
you were on stage with Harv eka Tihar
Becker and I remember just thinking wow
all right this guy you know you man half
I was maybe 18 you've thought about 10
years ago and you know if I'd have known
that ten years later I would be sat in
my house with you as good friends I
wouldn't believe they put in sort of the
mmm I thought hmmm like a million and
one in London at the Ibis Hotel that's
fantastic and then I think we met as
well in Thailand what's the next time we
met were the next time we met was when
yeah in Thailand you were checking in
bumped into you I heard you over
overheard you complaining to the
receptionist but there was no bath in
your room I even offered you that sounds
like me
that was you yes I remember that I was
like you can have my bath yeah anything
to be in with Marcos de Maria yeah you
want to be in the bath with me not in
the bath with you just in okay next it
all right okay and you were like it's
okay yeah I was put in Thailand that was
I think that was 2015 2016 what 50 for
five years I was teaching you how to
basically it better
you get a better speaker better speak
irresistible offers etc yeah because I
was in I've been in property for like
five years and I wanted to share my
message so I came to that program and
that completely changed my life again so
I got a lot to be thankful for and you
helped me massively with the trailmen on
the training side of the business and
you've done extremely well because I
remember you in the audience remember
out of everybody there I remember that
you were one of the few that had the
energy you know and and that's why I
kept in touch with you because you had
that energies also because we were both
from the UK yep
but did you ever think that you would be
when you were at in Thailand
making this stage offering to share your
bath with me did you ever think that
you'd be as successful as you are now no
I didn't in fact at that program making
the stage in Thailand it crushed me so
bad at one point I'm gonna be thinking
maybe I'm just not cut out for this you
know what stage was that which room was
that that was in wasn't in my room no no
no no in your room that that you were in
your room I think it was just on the
second or third day yeah I don't really
think yeah yeah I did that was good
that's a process we go that's good
that's good yeah and I'm ever thinking
maybe I'm not cut out to be a speaker
because I went a bit probably bit how I
got really thinking you know after so
many property I'm a great speaker and
I'll just polish up on my skills but
actually it crushed me and I maybe
thinking maybe I'm looking out for this
and then by the time I left although I
was broken they always break you and
then rebuild you and by the time I left
I know they just thinking it was rather
than thinking about the size of my
business or how many how many people I
could touch and how big my venues could
be it was more about trying to create
trying to create big people rather than
big numbers and after that I remember
just thinking I just want to help people
become the best version of themselves
they can pass on you know so a real kind
of trauma serve people rather than just
trying to seduce you think that helped
you so because when you make it about
yourself then sometimes some of the
limiting beliefs come up but when you do
it for other people there aren't any
limiting beliefs because yeah and it's
funny we're talking training so much
because I guess the thing we share in
common is we're both trainers
yeah we're also investors your your us
into stocks and all that stuff I'm into
property but they think we the reason
the thing that connected us to begin
with was the fact to train and yeah they
said the difference between a trainer
and a speaker is a speaker is it's all
about them which is what I used to be
when I speak on stage share my story
it's all about me and I gray and then
actually when you learn to be a trainer
it's certainly not about you it's about
them training them and you really helped
me with that so again really grateful
and the training business has been
brilliant it's always helped me
immensely because the best way to learn
is to teach and I've got very very good
at property my property business is
blown up as a result last year I bought
a castle and I'm doing a lot of big
development deals buying building
selling houses and yeah you know really
really enjoying life interesting point
so so actually by helping other people
but also by having to stay at the
forefront and at the bleeding edge of
what you teach people because the market
changes it's actually helped your
investing yeah for sure
I mean even doing YouTube videos like
I'm quite well-known on on YouTube for
doing YouTube videos about property
investment and doing a video every
single day sometimes I'll be like ah you
know what can I talk about and I'll
research and I just learned something no
so yeah for sure
I think teaching is just the best way to
know some things so I've become so
engrossed in in learning more and
becoming more and then and then you
produce more so brilliant yeah okay and
you decided on property what why is that
because I know that your mother was
involved in property is yeah so it is
that why property or I think the reason
I got into property was because I just
understood it so with you know with a
lot of oh I'm not I'm not the most
educated person you know in the world
and I just thought listen if I'm buying
a house the house is going to outlive me
it's it's you can see it you can touch
it you could feel that so I think that
was the initial thing I just really
wanted to buy a house so I bought my
first house and I did it strategically I
got creatively managed to do it without
using any of my own money
and when I got that first house and
rented it out I just I just got addicted
to it really and just kept kept building
my portfolio started with nothing
started and although my mom was in
property you know I grew up very you
know kind of humble humble family single
mom know I think that some some people's
parents have property but that doesn't
mean that the next generation picks it
up and you did what my mom my mom helped
me well she got married when I was 12
and my stepdad was a chartered
accountant and yet he didn't have any
mortgage on his house and and he just
before I left school he decided to
refinance the house and buy some
properties and I was like that sounds
cool yeah how can I get involved and he
didn't give me any money but what he did
was he believed in me and he was also a
mortgage host so my first property I was
too young to get a mortgage and he was
like a guarantor so you know again
grateful Arnold Schwarzenegger says no
one's self-made so whilst no one gave me
any money people have supported me given
the opportunities you've helped me so
you know but where does mindset and
psychology come in to this good you just
said something really interesting you
said I'm not particularly what did you
say educated okay but immediately what
sprung up for me is well hold on a
moment you you're talking at a formal
education yes but you're very self
educated yes
so you you are very educated yeah yeah I
guess I guess what I meant was school
when I left when I started in business I
wasn't educated and yeah massive
difference between Jim Rohn says this
self education formal education formal
education will make you a living self
education will make your fortune and and
I've spent I've said seven figures
millions of pounds on consultation
education personal development training
courses I mean that course that I went
on in Thailand was like maybe ten grand
yeah nolan's it so you say it wouldn't
at suic like would you say how much have
you spent over two million on your on my
education in the last ten years that is
a lot of money yeah and that includes
consultation as well like professional
consultation but I always say that it
doesn't matter I mean obviously not
everybody has that much but what I'm
assuming is you you paid for something
and you learnt what to do then you made
more money
you reinvested that money in your
education it's not like you had I've got
two million here teach me no no no it
was it was a slow it's like if you put a
pound in a slot machine and two pound
comes out you'd be crazy not to put more
money in so I started I mean when I was
17 I remember spending a couple of
thousand pounds on a property training
course but it felt like a lot as all of
my paper around money from a kid gone
you know it felt like a lot and people
said that's crazy
yeah 17 brilliant so I spent 2,000
pounds and it felt like a lot but then
I've got half so I'd have been crazy to
not think that I'm gonna go and get some
I'm gonna learn more but what what how
does what so if it doesn't end up like
what so we teach the different pillars
we don't teach them but we say there are
different pillars and you should have
not just one like a career or a job you
should have another one could be
property could be stocks it could be
internet marketing could be your
business or whatever it is yeah
so the pillars are very important to
make a solid foundation and the N and
Heather and you decided that property
was the main one for you as well as
business yeah okay and now you use
internet marketing in order to help them
i iack i actually differentiate the two
I know it's part of business yeah but
it's kind of its own pillar as well
because people are making so much money
out of it and we teach that eighty
percent of success is mindset would you
agree would you disagree what would you
say about that yeah I would say that 80%
of success is is the per is the person
and you can become that person it's not
a case of are you born with it or you're
not do you not think so
do I not I think what that you so you
don't think that you're born with no I
think you can learn it do you think some
people are born with it though well I I
think there's there's always genetics
there's what you want to be kind what
you mean by it yeah but being successful
is a is a learned skill great 100% yeah
but where do you need to have money
though because you spent two million no
but I started off by spending two
thousand from paper round's and then I
just worked up to - what if somebody
doesn't have two thousand well I did it
I did it with from paper yet so I mean I
get a friggin paper out exactly so it's
a let's put it yeah yeah yeah that's a
lot of paper round's mate oh yeah paper
mic mic night while I was
school I was the most crazy kid because
I had loads of paper round's I used to
buy and sell stuff at school
I am I in my holidays like I remember go
in my holidays are going go on a crash
course to learn how to plaster and for
my work experience can work on a
building site and then while I was at
school I used to advertise for my
plastering business because I could
plaster but because I was busy at school
and stuff and I couldn't really do it I
then used to a lot of people getting
made redundant plaster Murs and I'd send
them out to go and do the job and then I
would get the work and go 5050 and I was
like 15 well done but okay so here we go
again alright I'm gonna come back to my
previous question about it sounds to me
tell me if I'm right well yeah whether
you might have had a formal education
whatever but your street-smart yeah what
if somebody isn't street smart i but you
stay street smart
but i messed up a lot so i did that was
15 I mean right messes right okay so so
that's the other side maybe it wasn't
streets mom maybe I just was courageous
enough to do it you went through loads
of things that didn't work but that one
did yeah and that got you to the next
level then you've yeah something not
working always things aren't gonna work
right it's just a case of yeah just
doing lots of things and keep doing it
and then when you fail just try again or
learn from it and tweak it you can't say
it didn't work nothing just doesn't work
you just have to just do something a
little different and keep and then make
it work that's a powerful message so so
if that's the case if you don't want to
spend 10 years getting to the thing what
what do you need to do to speed up the
process just treat the price of
something working yeah I guess it
depends on what the end it what the end
or the end goal is well let's say it's
to have two properties for example yeah
and somebody like looking now would say
well I mean I don't really make enough
money now and now I've had all paper
round or something to make some money
and then you said okay I made loads of
mistakes as well hmm
in order to get to something that
actually did work so is there a way of
speeding up the process yeah getting I
think just to just just to find people
that don't Lee for and learn from them
but so be upset work harder Jim Rohn
says this gray Jim Rohn I love he says
work harder on yourself and you're doing
the job so I think most people don't
work hard on themself at all actually so
what does working on yourself and look
at yourself means deliberately getting
better at stuff or as a person
so rather than is that a skill or is
that a mindset is it both it could be
both so could that could part of that
could be meditation that's working on
yourself working on your well-being
working your on figuring yourself out
working on reading getting skills going
on seminars and courses just being I
mean I think I think the person who is
that the more the more obsessed you are
with getting better no one just becomes
successful by mistake it doesn't just
happen one mistake you've got it you've
got to get good again Jim Rohn are quite
him he says don't wish it was easier
wish you were better just get better so
interesting so you just said work more
on yourself than your job but if you're
spending eight hours or ten hours
working for somebody else are you saying
spend eight or nine hours or eleven
hours working on yourself what do you
mean by work more on yourself than your
job maybe I guess it could be in terms
of Alice but just in terms of focus mmm
yeah laser yeah laser focused on getting
back I mean even now I'm still obsessed
with getting better but you you I guess
you you do tend to waste a lot of time
in meetings and stuff like that in a job
yeah as opposed to just doing the actual
thing yeah they say like the average
employee just works for two to three
hours because it's almost probably so
that being the case then like what what
should people do like your mornings
lunch times evenings is it reading is is
is it listening to podcasts is it going
to your channel I mean what yeah and I
think is where if you say there's
someone you should read this many books
and do this much it's more of a it's a
falling in love with it you know so if
you if you really want have a burning
passion to get good at making money or
to get good at anything it's just it's
just something that you just do all the
time rather than saying you've got to do
this you've got to do that and I think
that is the root of being successful but
it successful
but actually the root is just being
obsessed with getting the scales and
getting good and that's why I run a
training company mm-hmm and then do you
think that if they chose which of the
five pillars was the right one for them
and they focus a laser beam focus on
themselves and on the material then the
money will follow yeah hundred percent
money's money is a result that's what
that's it millionaire mind intensive
money money is a result and I'll attend
I tend to focus that much on the money
these days for me I focus more on other
stuff only for Albert Einstein says
don't try and be successful trying to be
valuable and if you valuable then the
money will follow so you don't think
rich people focus on money of them I
don't know I mean I quote money's money
is the score right so keeping tap it
keeps tabs of how well you do so don't
get me wrong I am I am wanting to say
every month you know what do we make
what's going on what do we spend
what's i net profit but that's not on a
day to day I'm not thinking get money
get money get money that if anything I
guess people who don't have money and
you know lacking it at the moment yeah
that can change I say something when I
was really scared that if I really went
after Marie I'd fall in love with it
mm-hm and it would change me okay I know
you're religious you could be a
Christian so is that is that is it could
does it there's a quote in the Bible
what is the actual quote the actual
quote is that you cannot serve both God
and money
okay so explain that to me so the Bible
says you cannot serve God and also serve
money serve serve so is that what I
don't understand well for me and what
that used to mean was you have a qu you
have a choice you can either strive for
riches or you can strive to be a
spiritual good person but you can't have
both
so is that in what you said just now
about adding value to other people maybe
maybe I mean I mean I think that growing
up I'm in my church was an ex Brethren
Church and it was definitely the mindset
people would wear poverty like a badge
of honor
hmm you know so go from that I mean that
in my especially for everybody else's as
well yeah yeah yeah then it's good the
interesting thing that happened was when
I became wealthy when it became
successful you know some churches that
would celebrate that but almost not in a
healthy way because it was like if
you're rich and successful then that's
God blessing you okay but if you've got
problems and you're sick and you haven't
got money that's you've been punished by
God because you must be doing something
wrong you must be in sin oh wow okay so
they weren't but your church was isn't
wasn't like that right my church was the
opposite but actually it's the same
because the the the same message is that
there's a correlation between how good
you are as a person and how much money
you have and actually I don't think
there is a correlation interesting I
don't think that I don't think that I
don't think that you I've met people who
are really rich or complete jerks and
I've met people that are really poor who
a complete jerk they're just people
they're just people so no knowing that
there's no correlation between how good
you are how much money you have because
actually if you say how much money I
have defines me as a person then I think
that's just a bit messed up that's a bit
of a slippery slope yeah because if you
value yourself because of something and
you lose it then your value goes down
yeah how does that yeah I don't
personally and here's what I think you
can't I mean you start doubting yourself
yeah yeah yeah but the quote as a
Christian yeah what I realized was that
you can't
maybe you can't serve God hamster firmly
but you can serve God through money and
money is just a tool that could be used
think oh so now I do a lot of work I've
got a charity Samuel Leeds Foundation
and if it wasn't for my business I won't
be able to fund that right it's actually
millions at all yes to do good or well
yeah to do whatever so what about the
other quotes then which is you know
people say that your money is the root
of all evil where is the actual quote I
think is the love of money yes and then
I stupid that I actually studied ancient
Greek in Hebrew okay and the the the the
phrase their love of money in the Bible
it's actually one word I can't remember
the word but what it means is is it's
it's it's an absolute obsession
never-ending yeah that's what it's
talking about so and again if you if you
hold anything like this it's not good
well
you just lose who you are you identity
yeah and not only that but not just
money that's anything anything you if
you if you clean you lose yourself
there's something that's to a
relationship another person yeah my
pasta Carrie Spicer he says that
everything on this earth is release hold
we come in with nothing we leave with
nothing we're just stewards in between
and I love that was he into property as
well I think it sounds like it yeah he's
a great guy but but just the whole
concept of having a lot of money but
holding it with open hands yes having a
lot of knowledge but being open with it
well it's not ours anyway is it it's
just energy yeah and we have it for a
bit then we pass on yeah it's not I'm
gonna take it with us
no because oh and when you when you hold
things with open hands and the generous
heart you're actually open to receive
more as well mmm
when you hold it like this it's just
yeah I don't think it's healthy so
whilst I make a lot of money and I'm
very proud to make a lot of money
because I've worked really hard I think
that it is important when you do have a
responsibility in a duty of care to be
responsible with that I really I really
believe that ya know I'm sure you do
yeah yeah so I know you've had a lot of
success financially I know you've had a
lot of success in property which then
also is financially I know you've had a
lot of success helping other people
doing the same yeah you get a lot of
people who really enjoy your shows
especially when you go out there and I
want to talk about in a moment where you
go and you you know you go back and as
if you were starting from zero again and
you get yourself and they're not a lot
of people would in fact I don't know
anybody who does that right but you must
also get some haters as well yeah how do
you deal with that
there's haters there's critics and
there's trolls and a critic is a critic
is someone that will tell you something
that you doing is not good but usually
with the intention for you to be better
that's good so ever tips are good
critics like great I like critic yeah I
always listen I'll always respond
yeah like critic so critic much just
feedback yeah Sam you all the music on
your YouTube videos it's just too loud
and had to distract from the message
sort it out bang a critic or give a
thumbs up yeah so thanks for the
feedback we're saying my business we
just improved our business by one
percent yeah exactly
awesome a hater is someone that may be
used just jealous or
well they've had a really bad day and
they're taking that out on you okay so
they'll just say you know you're fat
whatever and haters I just love them
bless them you know I'll just sort of
psychic yeah yeah there's a book that's
called huggy haters and it just says
just love your hangers because it's and
the Bible says a soft answer turns away
wrath you know just more nice yeah so
just love the haters and then there's
trolls and the troll is someone that
will just you know very deranged people
or strange people that will just
continually spam you so they sound
obsessed very obsessed you were just
saying they're holding on to yeah yeah
yeah and now just like comment on every
video and and all that those people I
just block so it sounds like they
actually had the problem sometimes some
of my trolls who just you know seems you
just hate me on my message very strange
people like I'll click on them so on
Facebook and then I'll click on the
message box and I'll see actually like
two years ago they were saying Sam I
love your videos come with me for coffee
question what question what question
mark oh and actually we're obsessed with
me in a very strange love way you didn't
reply maybe I yeah I didn't reply
because I get too many messages source
and then that that love obsession turns
into a high obsession and then that's
why they just trial very hosting so
those people you know I mean hey I love
them any I love them I haven't got any
you didn't give them significance maybe
maybe it's maybe it's my fault but
someone said how do you deal with
jealous people I said I don't deal with
that's for them to deal with yeah you
know it's not my issue so yeah I mean I
guess I'm just doing my thing I always
say for every one hater you've helped
100 so you don't look too much I know
that some downfall you know about the
likes and I mean you must go oh look but
but you don't like go oh I've got so
many and if I don't and you're what you
were saying before your your your
feeling of worth doesn't go down don't
have any or up you I mean don't get me
wrong if a video goes viral if I get
loads of using the video yeah it's great
and I like it and I check it and read
the comments and stuff but I think
there's the online world and then
there's the real world and sometimes you
do need to separate the two because you
can be you know really popular one
minute online and then suddenly
next minute really unpopular and people
are very fickle and you can't control
them no and there's keyboard warriors
and there's this so I never let my mood
or my worth or my anything depend on
what people are saying online you just
focus on your thing you just do that
your real world and some people like it
some yeah even now like we're doing this
interview it's great this is the real
world right now
but then this will be put onto the
online world and I'm not too interested
I'm more interested in this conversation
right now and then when people are
discussing that into this interview
later online I'll be focused on the next
conversation and I'll be doing the next
so I don't get too obsessed with what's
happening online
um despite me putting videos out every
day and having a big online presence
some very active on social media
I just yeah if my business is running
well if I'm helping people I'm running
nice events I've got a beautiful family
I'm just focusing on that and I don't
get too hung up about this mmm that's
pretty but you know I asked you
off-camera earlier whether you're
somebody who has quite thick skin yeah
do you yes and do you think with with
people that I haven't got close to my
life I haven't got a thick skin with my
wife
if my wife raises her eyebrows I'm like
okay what's up great distinction yes
yeah but it's everybody out there yeah
who you know there might be there might
be ten people where I've got thin skin
I'm really even you life if I sense that
you're upset with me or if you I'd be
I'd be concerned by hey let's chat are
we okay you know if I sensed there was
an issue I'd be I'd be wanting to sort
it I would be splat I don't care but
then online or if I'm on stage and I'm
yeah I am thick-skinned so that that's
really and that's a really nice message
I think for some people because I think
a lot of people out there they kind of
react to everything there's a time to
react and there's a time not to react
very good so what do you think somebody
who's just starting out it forget about
whether it's property or stocks or
whatever what would be your top advice
advice to those people just starting out
ah if you're just starting out what I'd
probably say is rather than thinking
about where you want to be in ten years
think about where you want to be in one
month what do you want to achieve in one
month and then put down put down an
action plan of one on one month one
month
okay and then go do that because
sometimes people think all I think all
used people will disagree on this but I
used to have a five-year plan a ten-year
plan now I don't because I could write a
ten-year plan and then I could achieve
in six months and then one we're going
to just relax for nine and a half years
I'd rather say actually I'm gonna put a
plan shorts it I don't plan for more
than a year really I mean I might little
bit but generally speaking I'm not in
detail so you have a short plan and then
go to town on it so so let's just
starting out okay what are the next
steps where could you fees it what what
what could you do where do you want to
be in a month's time okay I wanna I want
to have I want to have one property or I
want to have I want to become competent
in stocks so I can actually do my first
trade okay so if that's what you want to
be then what activity do you need to do
over the next month to make that happen
I need to do this this they go to this
course and read this book meet up for
coffee with this person set up an
account okay
then go do that you know what I love
about that is that it's measurable
whereas if you say five years you have
to wait five years to see whether you've
achieved it was it one month I was
expecting to say year or two years but
one month then in four weeks you'll know
yeah and then you can adapt yeah that's
pretty old you say I'd say if you just
starting out I mean always important to
get around people you know get around
good people people that are starting out
doing so anything new like when I went
on my property course when I started out
and I use my paper and money people said
you know people would tell me how
shouldn't we do that well that's really
risky what are you doing a lot money
yeah so people will when you start out
and you're going to expect people will
sometimes because they want to protect
you sometimes because your success will
remind them of the hair lack of or
you're taking action will remind you
know so there will be people that are
going to try and bring you down yes
so I would say expect that and make sure
that you said when you starting out you
surround yourself with people that
actually want you just succeed I think
that's really important did you do that
or did people try and drag you down
either mixture okay so you did have
people who yeah I mean my stepdad my mom
they've been supporting me I did have
people that really didn't
for me had a mixture and some of the
people have supported me in the early
days then didn't support me a bit later
on okay you got enough houses now you
know yeah it's really limits too much
yep yeah yeah good for you man you got
your first house at 1700 why you got six
now at nineteen all right you got enough
now you good mm-hmm
okay you don't let money change you
though be careful and it's like wow you
were like my biggest supporter in the
early days and then other people I know
and also never try and win people over
too much well I see people in there
saying I just need to persuade my wife
or I just did it there's that thing you
were talking about again they cannot
hold on too much and then they lose
their identity trying to yeah sometimes
you got to let go that's that's hard
though right yeah it is because
ultimately I never just got my wife as
my other half because she's a her person
on my person so we're one but we're also
one alone as well you know so and you
just got a text possibility for your own
life and rather than people way around
they're starting out that white waiting
for their friend or waiting for their
husband or waiting and it's like you
don't wait for anyone this is your life
yeah but you don't seem to wait around
for anybody like you just seem to get an
idea and you go for it it's almost like
you don't even care what the result is I
mean I've seen some of your videos you
don't do you really care what the result
is or it's more about the doing of it
and you're about of the video or just
generally just generally I mean of
course I care about the result but yeah
I don't overthink things because I the
most dangerous place to be is to stand
still so if you're you know thinking too
much just do it you could you could kind
of think yourself out of anything can
you but also if you if you step out in
the wrong direction you can always
change you know if you can always change
you move if you just standing still
thinking about stuff like if your work
were in show these stocks I should have
any property you can think about it
forever just choose one choose the wrong
one
yeah and just go and do it really and
then after a month if it's the wrong one
then you can just slip into it the other
it doesn't matter but just do something
but do you think you need to have this
this thing which I think most people are
missing or maybe they're not let's have
a discussion confidence confidence comes
from knowledge confidence comes from
knowledge yeah Samuel can you help me
become more confident I'm just not
confident myself you know confidence you
don't you didn't really do it you
probably shouldn't be confident if I
were you I'd be very unconfident to so
what you need is you need the knowledge
see if I'm playing a board game or the
rules I'm gonna be really I'm confident
about meet my win and I should be
whereas if I learn the rules know
exactly what to do it exactly where to
put what to put where suddenly I'm
confident so I think in it and it's the
same in business if you if you know what
you're doing then confidence comes you
don't need a mentor and someone to give
you I just need to know what to do is to
be trained but hold on then you do need
a mentor well you might okay of course
you need something yes you need to be
trained yeah you might need to read the
book but you might need to attend the
class you might need to but you don't
need someone to you know sort of like
coach you through it and tell you how
great you are and I I don't think I've
no I don't need that what do you think
your top beliefs are for success like
what what belief do you have about
yourself yeah well I can I believe that
I'm not better than anybody but no one's
better than me but Wow okay so if it's
been done I can do it okay that's a good
one yeah all right go i serious like
okay you're on stage in front of 500
people the millionaire mind intensive on
18 okay well if he learned to do that
and if he can impact the people then I
can because he's not better than me
brilliant and it doesn't take it away
from me you're doing it no but then I'm
on stage and I'm teaching people I'm not
so I don't think I'm better than anyone
in the audience so I think I think you
maybe know more about myself but you're
not bad but I'm not better because they
can figure that out okay yeah what other
beliefs do you think that you have that
make you successful I think I think I
just I think my disability I just
believe in myself and I just think money
doesn't define you and he's just I just
I just think having a curve in a belief
in yourself okay so I was trying to Lou
to that earlier with confidence is
believing in yourself slightly different
than confidence esteem okay so
confidence is I shouldn't be confident
in at this at this because I don't know
about
but I have the confidence that I can go
and get the knowledge and I can do it so
confidence in yourself all of these
elements in the matter oh yeah so I
think there are different yeah so if you
said to me hey let's go on let's go and
do let's go and play a game of golf I
won't be very very confident about that
because I'm not great at golf okay but
if but I've got the confidence that I
could be great if I really wanted to yes
yes don't yeah absolutely
yeah but self belief is something that
you have yeah okay what's self belief
and how can people get more self belief
I mean self belief for me self belief is
it I don't know how you can I don't even
know the answer to that but so
foundational isn't it yeah it is it is
it is I don't know whether whether I can
even answer that well I mean how can you
get self belief just act as if you've
got it even if you haven't I guess okay
how do you do that by budget bite bite
rather than worrying about whether you
have it or not what do you want to
achieve just go do it
stop overthinking it yeah but they might
they might not like me or I might get
criticized yeah it's so much easier not
doing anything actually I'll do it
tomorrow I'll do it next week next year
I have an ex I mean that way of thinking
like if you care what other people think
you just you just caught on it's just
game over I mean it's funny because when
you become successful you don't get
rejected that much when I started all
over again from scratch that was when I
remembered what rejection feels like I'm
ever thinking I haven't been this
rejected in a decade okay
it's really funny ya think that
something that you can lose so I mean we
better tell the people watching this
what you did you really put your money
well on Malthus I was just had balls on
the line okay all right all that money
where your mouth is bye-bye literally
you I think was fifty pounds and you had
a week to make it from scratch
I've got dumped in a random location
where I didn't know the area with a very
dodgy wig dressed in disguise with an
old yellow bag a car 50 pound in my
pocket and I was
only when I left my house to go do the
challenge and under my wife was just
crying because she knew I was not
allowed to come home I'd been cut off
from my bank account been cut off
everything I wasn't allowed home until
it become financially free ia had enough
passive income through property to cover
the average person's life which is 2,000
pound a month what were you trying to
achieve with that I was trying to
achieve because I became financially
free so young and so long ago and now
I'm doing property so many people say
are that the market is different now
or is different for me because I haven't
got any money oh yeah but the thing is
and they have all the excuses so I I
took everybody's excuse and I put it
upon myself to inspire people and to
show people that actually it really is
possible and also if you have the
knowledge though right if you have the
knowledge okay because without the
knowledge the knowledge is it right and
I always say knowledge and scale is more
important than than how much money you
have right now so yeah that's what I did
so I spent when I remember saying to
Amanda I was like I genuinely hope to
see you at Christmas like I didn't know
when I was and I just booked that but
months off and I did not know whether I
would be coming home anytime soon but I
I chief financial freedom and I did in a
week seven days which is just ridiculous
and it made BBC news yeah you had like
over way over a million hits yeah 1.5
million views on YouTube yeah I made the
beat I was on BBC news 6 o'clock news it
was today you know it was all over the
newspapers and it was just incredible
and it and as a result of that that has
helped many people get their life sorted
out their finances sorted out and then
achieved so much because you gave them
belief I gave him belief yeah and I also
in the documentary showed them step by
step a step exactly what I was doing ok
but let's just say that they did watch
the documentary 10 times right which
people wouldn't write but it's in there
so why not yeah it down once again take
notes etc and then take action on it but
they might not have and I'm coming back
to it again that cell
belief in themselves to do it yeah
anything right I am a property investor
and I'm also a trainer and I teach
people about property and I don't teach
I don't really teach people about self
belief much because my attitude is and
and and there's some people that don't
and there's people that run courses on
tell belief and confidence I don't do
that I just think I'll just teach others
teach the skills if you've got the
confidence and the wherewithal and the
tenacity and the courage to apply these
principles and then you're going to be
successful if you haven't then you're
not so I don't really know that much
about confidence and self-belief it I
don't know much about it all I know is
property that's it so and I say anyone
can do this and then sometimes say yeah
but there can't that's not true I've
been challenged on this even my pasta we
have we have we have arguments yeah and
he says not anyone can do it there
because they haven't got what it takes
and it's like but they can just think
they haven't got what it takes so he's
talking about the mindset again he said
I'm saying they can no they might not
yes so you're saying they could if that
yeah but what I guess I mean this is a
really interesting discussion especially
you know because of what you just said
because if you believe that 80% of
success really is mindset and you're
teaching 20% but here's the thing right
when I show people the steps and the
scales what to do bam bam bam yeah ABC
what happens is people's mindset changes
because when they see how it's done then
they have confidence now some people
maybe not maybe some people are just so
like screwed up in here also also
worried about because the thing is right
here's the thing there's 10 million
reasons why even if I show someone do
this this this and then you're gonna
make some money
mm-hmm like they change the recipe
immediately but you say don't do ABC and
they'll go well I can't work out Jim
Rohn says don't sign up for the classes
and I was stopped by a homeless guy okay
and he said to me please can I have two
pounds I'm starving and I'm homeless
I said you really heard what he said
yeah I said okay I said I'll give you 2
pounds history of pounds I get me two
pounds and I said but if you can
to my crash course here's the details
turn up stay for the whole two days I'll
give you two thousand pounds here's your
two pounds but I'll give you two
thousand just for showing up did he show
he didn't show up now I could go why
didn't he show up why didn't he and I
can go on and on thinking about it but
I'd rather not I'd rather just focus on
the people that do show up right so I'm
not I'm not I'm not really that
concerned about the people that have you
know the access to the training have the
access to the YouTube videos are in the
country I mean come on we're in a
country where there's so much open to
all the knowledge all the train all the
books you're in a first world country
with the opportunities like and you
can't become successful then you are
either really sucky or you just don't
want it right and it's the sucky bit
that that's the thing so we very much go
into the the pain pleasure because we
think that there's two motivations
there's the running away from pain and
there's running towards pleasure and
what I what I believe I believe that in
the short term people need more pain
yeah in order to move and they need to
be reminded that of that pain because
what they do is they eat too much they
drink too much they watch too much TV
they go out too much in order to hide
that pain yeah instead of what what I
try and do is I try and say no actually
it sucks your situation sucks and I try
and give them some paint now I explain
to them what I'm doing so that they can
give themselves more pain so that they
actually I don't know what what do you
think about that I don't know okay so
you're just look here are the skills
yeah they work for me yeah and follow
them you will as well but whether you do
it or not is it's kind of up to you I'm
not your dad yeah absolutely and and and
listen and my events like I'll phone up
an agent and I'll make an offer I'll put
forward so you do that like yeah yeah
and the agent will be like oh no we
don't do that I'll put the phone down on
me and then I'll say now look guys if
you're not prepared to be told what I
was just told yes if for you that would
be like
then you in the wrong industry yeah
because look she just said no am i any
poorer am i any weaker so where's the
wind that you do anyway don't know then
you do teach the mindset I like mindset
that is noise that are you're preparing
them yeah I think I do to you pretty
very much it by example and wrapped up
in even better yeah you maybe don't make
it so Evert as I do but you you
basically like that and then the
learning goes in make probably do teach
mindset I think I probably do I think
I've seen clips of you and I just don't
deliberately do it it just oozes out of
me I remember this one time when you
were on stage on crutches and this guy
did he delete that video but it was
getting too much height oh really
yeah I actually really liked that video
did yeah yeah I should delete it but
yeah but it was so it was the truth yeah
because I just got back from Uganda mmm
I lost 25% my blood I was told to stay
in hospital but I left to go run an
event hold on we got to tell people what
this is all about so you went to Uganda
you went on a waterfall and you're in a
boat yeah with clients with my success
student we went out on a charity trip it
was the first day team-building
experience the boat capsizes you went
over the waterfall fell down the
waterfall were all injured luckily no
one was to injured apart from me you
were massively and my kneecap was
shattered or broken it would see bones
sticking out my knee blood shooting up
lost $0.25 my blood I remember seeing
pictures of your eyes and spent 10 days
in Ugandan hospital with no food mm-hmm
they did the operation on me managed to
get back to the UK was told I would
never walk properly again I'd always
have a limp on a crutch which was
emotionally tough to be told that and
then four days later was running an
event a training event and there was a
dude in the audience it was coming with
so many excuses and it got about my
wheelchair and my crutches you let rip I
just let rip because he was just kind of
loads of excuses but the thing is the
broken mindset but that's that's a
brokenness that what you did right there
cuz I remember the video I remember and
that is that is mindset now it could be
that that one person or somebody
watching goes wow that's a bit tough but
I can promise you
would've been 10 times that many people
on the other side of the audience that
went I got it now I feel like there and
then on the day everybody got it
including the guy yeah and he actually
thanked me for it but then on the video
because it was almost outcome it's out
of context people just think wow the
other come to me banging my crutches
together four minutes of the yes out of
context that that's the challenge with
documentaries right that's the challenge
with you know because they're out of
context yeah most things that you see on
TV and of context most things that are
reported about Donald Trump are totally
out of context yeah yeah I agree I agree
so yeah that was the but I am you know
I'm allergic to not broke people but
broke minded people like that whole
coming up of excuses and even people
come up to me in their say you know a
and I'll stop and straight away say well
I'm 19 years old and I haven't got any
money and what are and and they're about
to ask me in there what advice would you
give me and I'll just say just stop
right there
here's my advice don't go around saying
I'm 19 and I haven't got money I haven't
stop right there
rather than writing down all right in
your mind having registered all the
problems and all the reasons where you
can't succeed you've got to scrap that
story and you've got to come up to what
you have got going for you so right now
tell me what you have going for me oh
I'm not sure what you hear at the event
why yeah I just really want to be
successful okay so straightaway you're
being trained you really have a burning
desire to be successful like this is the
story that I want to hear so don't come
in sound 19 I've got no money and blah
blah blah blah blah what would advice
would you give me say to me
Sammy walk I'm prepared to be trained
I'm really hungry I've got a fire in my
ballet I've got a lot of time on my
hands because I've just finished school
hmmm what advice would you give them
that's the other side of the same coin
they just saw the other side because
they're totally the other side right I'm
90 years old that's a truism but I've
just and I've got lots of time but in 19
the reason they tell you in that 19 is
because it's a disclaimer as on only 19
mmm don't tell me you know I don't care
yeah you're not 19 you just are do you
think that that is a because we were
talking about cause and effect do you
think that that is like the effect of a
serious problem we have in society yeah
which is I'm just putting it out there
the lack of parenting I mean I don't
know if it's parenting it might be
everything it's just the whole system
and the whole school either we are we
are programmed and brainwashed to be
poor right from birth the school
education system the banks the media the
government is all there to brainwash us
to be poor yeah and I know that sounds
out sickly outlandish or extreme but it
just is the case yeah and I know this
because I like you know now I'm rich and
I go in the meetings and I hear that and
the super-rich want all the money and
the super-rich don't want the average
person to be financially educated either
yeah and that's why we enough not to
cause too much of a problem just enough
yeah into the just to comply yeah
because the government cannot control
you if you are financially free
so hey and in the back why will the bank
to not give you a 20,000 pound loan to
buy a property but then they'll give it
you to get married yeah that's right
they'll give you a loan for a new
kitchen yeah but not to invest in a
stock market they'll give you a loan to
go on holiday but they'll tell you to
invest it in a properties to risk a come
on and and they'll tell you to put your
much save hearts work hard save up money
and put it in the bank where it's safe
but they don't do that they use your
money on the very thing that they tell
you skew risky today that's right yeah
come on right now oil is in is at a
price where I'm telling every single one
of my my graduates and demanding of my
mentees that they get in and use the
strategy that we use and I'm angry if
they don't is such a no-brainer
investment right now yeah and where
they'd probably make you know whatever
ten percent and what you get in the bank
1% ha if you're lucky huh yeah half in
Germany you're now paying the bank to
hold the money it's just yeah people say
to me no actually I'm not doing too but
I've got a zero point I'm like listen
listen listen it starts with a zero is
bad Wow
do you know some people they say I wish
the good old days
we were back to 4% or 5% I said what
would you do with 5% just think about
this right you need in order to make 50
grand and have a okay life and have
choice whether you work or not you need
a million pounds in the bank account at
5% to give you 50,000 so what it's and
if you have a million pounds in the bank
and then the bank goes bust you'll be
left of 75 grand hmm it's not safe
yeah it is not a safe place because the
government guarantees up to yeah it's
like all the schemes thought the ISIS
it's like you put money into a nicer lot
they call it a leak so a lifetime
eyesore account where the government say
save save money save money save money
put it in the icer and then when you go
to buy a house we'll give you 25% top up
right towards the house which sounds
generous on the government's part but
there isn't it is because they want you
to get into this small-mindedness
safe safe safe for our house to live in
I mean our notes more honest because
they say you can't put more than four
grand a year in there so in your mind
listen in your mind it's like okay so I
can't have more than four grand a year
in and I need to save up to but I can I
have to put in the house to live in I
can't invest it so straight away you
think four grand a year so that means
that in a probably bout six seven years
I bought my first house straightaway
they got you in that slow work that it's
the same with the pensions just say okay
most people have what thirty thousand in
there on average yes some people have
nothing in their pension but you can
only put a certain amount in a year yeah
after one one and a half million and
it's going down and down and down and
down every single year then it all
becomes taxable so it's totally mixed
messages yeah this it's like it's if
they want you to be slow and
small-minded and dependent on them even
with these some of these schemes like
the ISIS and they say oh if a new
government comes into power if anything
we could change air and then you think
[ __ ] do I do it or don't but it's just
like last messages yeah what yeah just
complete by the way III I say to people
you know open up a trading and investing
eisah because you can put up to twenty
thousand adult per household so if we
were married then it
would be I could put into it you put 20
if I don't wanna marry you share a bath
that's it that's it yeah
well we'll see what happens step-step
part of successes or ones wonderful time
and then if we have like a teenage son
like a teen except that's another 25 so
it's sixty thousand you could fare it
away but the strategies I teach are not
saving it's just a wrapper to invest and
grow that money yeah it's to grow not
stay there what is worth saving I don't
understand saving I just don't get it
know what I'm saving for I used I used
to think like that but now you know it
does not everyone I used to think like
that of course save money what for yeah
what so they were rainy day so that it
can just shrink as the inflation goes
out right that's right yeah yeah and we
and no one knows what inflation the real
inflation rate actually is but let's say
it's five six percent or whatever and
we're getting 1% in the eye side I mean
you're losing money every single year
you put 50 grand in the bank and then
you wait ten years it's probably worth
about 36 equivalent you put it into a
property and not only does the property
go up but also if you've bought smart
you've used a mortgage service so the
money doesn't go up in value actually
the house goes up in value which means
you've certainly got a lot of leverage
you know so and that's one of the reason
all that property because you can
leverage so so so well that's why I know
there's pros and cons on our debates
about is equity better than than
property I mean I think property is
great as you know I think stocks are
great and I think that ultimately I mean
the best thing to invest is what you
know exactly and I think that I know
property really really or which one
whichever one you choose right like you
said just choose one yeah if you don't
like you can always go to the other one
but choose one imaginar Warren Buffett
had never said you know I don't know I'm
not gonna do anything he'd be what you
know do complem one of them anyway you
can do both but if you're not doing
either right now just pick one and just
go for it yeah we do both you do but
you're you're in kryptos as well yeah
yeah it helped with your with your
helpful advice I'll text you where
should I buy yeah brilliant
anything else you'd like to say to the
audience to help them be even more
successful than they are right now yeah
you know what I think what I would say
just start you know just just start get
good people around you and have fun
along the way
you know enjoy enjoy the process because
sometimes when I when I look at where
I'm at now
you know that you know the success the
money whatever I look back and I think
actually it was really good fun building
it up so enjoy it don't don't be
thinking when I get to this point then
I'll be happy when I get this much money
then about me just enjoy the process and
thus a process not journey because
journey would say let's see where I go
where this process is if I do this this
this is going to happen so enjoy that
process very nice thanks um hey welcome
man
[Music]